well I'm saying that we don't need men
in society of course we do we're talking
about relationships yeah you're strong
but the thing is I can live my life as a
woman and not need a man what a woman
oh pearls stop in my day-to-day life I
don't need a man to fix my car I'll just
go to the mechanics what is the
mechanical man you're a woman no no I'm
saying yes we need man in society but in
relationship the only reason I actually
need you is because I want you I don't
actually need you
I need you I need you to procreate yes I
agree but the things I don't need you in
my day-to-day life but wait wait wait
what if someone breaks into your house
I'll just call the police okay what if
they don't come what if the average
place in the US it takes like things
in the US it takes like 15 that is for
them to get that's not realistic
these two guys in your in your house
what are you doing that's not realistic
I've not had any man break into my house